My name is Lexi Ibañez and I’m a fourth-year political science major
with a minor in global studies.
There’s a bunch of academic opportunities for us here at UCLA.
I remember one of the first classes I ever took at UCLA was called
Space Weather.
And I was like, “Wait, there’s weather in space?”
Stuff like this, there’s classes you’ve never even heard about.
There are big lecture classrooms,
and small seminars. And that’s only the beginning.
What makes UCLA so amazing is that these experiences and these opportunities are out there.
You’re centered in Los Angeles, and there’s a huge network here.
I mean as far as field trips are concerned, internships...
I was working as a research consultant for NASA, and I was so shocked - I was shocked!
There are internships and programs for studying abroad, too.
I ended up going to Hong Kong for a semester.
I took a Chinese characters class
—I learned like 300 Chinese characters.
Exploring different majors and minors is part of designing your future.
I actually ended up taking lots of different classes in different
fields, different majors, different departments.
And I ended up taking Fiat Lux.
A Fiat Lux is just a one-unit course that a professor teaches.
I took one on European Socialism.
Images of the earth.
American Indian Studies.
It exposed me even in my first quarter to something I was interested in
and wanted to be a part of, with students with similar ideas.
Besides taking a Fiat Lux, you can take Freshman Clusters
and honors programs, designed specifically for first-year students.
The breadth of what I was able to learn that first year
helped me focus on what I wanted to do.
UCLA is a research university, first and foremost.
It’s one of the preeminent research facilities of its kind.
Most of its departments are in the top 10.
You’re getting the best education you could get anywhere,
and you’re getting instruction from professors who are experts in their field.
There are so many incredibly smart people here who think in all different types of ways.
People here are very, very motivated. Everyone wants to learn,
and everyone is motivated for whatever their passion is.
I remember one day realizing, “Wow, no other school has this. You can’t top this.”
I’m here, I’m a part of this. This is where I’m supposed to be.
This has been the best four years of my life, and I hope you’ll come to UCLA and experience it for yourself.